I don't like this I don't from my
perspective I don't like or enjoy
conversation that is dictating how women
use their bodies but then doesn't do the
same thing for men
who are these like I I don't I that's
what I like if we're going to be having
conversations like okay would woman How
would how how would a man feel if a
woman slept with multiple men I would
like to have the same conversation about
how a man the inverse of that so okay
I'll give you I'll give you I'll give
you the examples okay so again we can't
undo biology so would you agree that
like when women start running out of
time to have kids like they start to
think more about it if they want kids
right typically of course it's awesome
right because because it's in the back
think about it every month right right
right right so but we because we can't
undo our biology right so so the closer
like 90 of our eggs are gone by 30.
exactly so the closer we get to 30 we we
start thinking about it more right yes
and it becomes more to the Forefront of
our mind